-Hey, everyone.
It is the end of the week.
That's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox, return emails,
and of course,
I send out thank you notes.
And I was just wondering if I
could write out a couple
thank you notes right now,
if that's okay with you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, could I get some thank
you note writing music, please?
[ Piano playing ]
Thank you very much.
[ Note trills ]
Oh, stop.
You know you gave a little
r-r-ring on that little --
♪ Da-da-rrring ♪
[ Note trills ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Sony's new PlayStation 5,
or as I call you,
the reverse Oreo.
[ Piano music stops ]
[ Scattered laughter ]
[ Soft slurp ]
I love when you can hear me lick
the envelope.
[ Laughter ]
Makes you feel good.
Wakes you up a little bit.
[ Clears throat ]
♪♪
Thank you, new Apple Watch,
for being able to measure
blood oxygen levels.
That's great info to have
right after I get a notification
that Grubhub is here
with my cheesesteak.
[ Laughter ]
[ Mimics slurp ]
-I wish.
♪♪
Thank you, Joe Biden's CNN
town hall drive-in
for inspiring a lot of people
with your message of unity
and really confusing one family
who thought they were there
to see "Scoob."
[ Laughter ]
-Spot on.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
President Obama's new memoir,
for being 768 pages long.
Although, to be fair, 600 of
those pages are just "Uhh."
[ Laughter ]
That was for you.
That was for you, Barack.
[ As Barack Obama ] Uhhhhhhhh...
Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Easy Mac,
for being there for those of us
who can't quite handle
difficult mac.
[ Laughter ]
[ Southern accent ] 82
ingredients?
The heck kind of macaroni
and cheese is this?
Well, first I guess I got
to grate the cheese,
put it in the dehumidifier,
and dry it.
Then I put it in the Cuisinart
and pulverize it
into said powder,
and then I have to --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Normal voice ] Thank you,
smirks, for letting me know
which members of a Zoom meeting
are DM-ing each other.
[ Laughter ]
That's a thinker, man.
-Yeah.
-I started with a stinker,
ended with a thinker.
-Yep.
Hmm.
♪♪
-Thank you,
shopping for a mattress,
for being a great way to show
strangers
the weird positions
you sleep in.
Let me try this thing out.
[ Laughter ]
Are you a fetal position dude?
-I'm like, you know, I guess
a grass hopper position.
-Like a praying mantis
type of deal?
-Kind of. I use my arm as, like,
a pillow, the one arm,
but then I take this arm
and I sort of go like this.
-Where's the pillow?
-My arm is the pillow.
-No pillow?
-Sometimes the pillow would
be underneath this arm.
-Yeah, stack it around?
-Yeah. Yeah.
I get my stack on.
-I started doing full on
just like that.
-That's just --
Like, come on, man.
-Like water slide.
[ Laughter ]
I water slide to sleep.
That's it.
And then during the night,
I'll wake up or something like
that, and then sometimes,
I'll do the plunge...
-Oh, man.
-...full face down.
And then I try that.
Doesn't quite work.
Nancy doesn't like it.
So one arm will go in.
You know?
My back's all screwed up.
-Michelle sleeps with one leg
up, but it never stays up.
If I wake up and her leg is up,
then I'm kept awake by the sound
of it gradually slipping down.
[ Laughter ]
Her foot just like sliding down
the sheet.
-Come on. Get it over with.
-It's like, "uhhhhhhhh."
[ Laughter ]
-Creeping along, yeah?
-Sometimes I like
just knock her leg down and just
act like I'm asleep again.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah, here we go.
The last thank you note.
-Aww.
-But it was...
[ Somber music plays ]
[ Voice breaking ]
It was so fun.
We had some bad ones.
We had some good ones.
-Did we, though?
-Yeah. We definitely had
some good ones.
[ Laughter ]
That first one was not bad,
was it?
No, the PlayStation 5,
reverse Oreo.
-Yeah.
-That was pretty good.
It's a joke for the future.
[ Laughter ]
-It's your birthday, man,
go ahead.
-Yeah, thanks, man.
-You're welcome.
[ Clears throat ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Batman,
for being an anti-masker
despite the fact
that you're wearing a mask.
[ Laughter ]
There you have it.
Those are my thank you notes.